shout out to Hassan nahan he said on
Twitter I can't get over Stephen Crowder
having his 50 million dollar paid docked
for getting banned if he does too much
racism when he's being hired by the
daily wire to do blackface and every
other flavor of bigotry Hassan's
obviously joking I thought it was a
really really funny tweet I think it's
funny getting hired to do blackface and
then uh Seth Dillon of the Babylon B he
won the day I love stuff I love Seth he
said I didn't want to make this video I
wanted to take a nap but my hand was
forced and then he he makes this video
where he was like the daily wire thought
Stephen Crowder was talking about them
how cute it was really really funny so
shout out I thought those were funny